en france où les infirmiers
anesthésistes sont en grève aujourd'hui
très sollicité depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire ils réclament notamment
des hausses de salaires et une véritable
reconnaissance des rassemblements
étaient organisés dans plusieurs villes
de l'hexagone notamment à paris devant
l'hôpital georges pompidou où s'est
rendu notre reporter n'a déjà de la zac
ils sont une centaine d'infirmiers
anesthésistes à s'être mobilisés
aujourd'hui devant l'hôpital georges
pompidou à paris pour faire entendre
leurs revendications
épuisé par la crise sanitaire liée au
kobus 19 ils réclament une
reconnaissance réglementaire
législatives et financière de leur
profession à hauteur de leur niveau de
formation alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il ya un peu plus de 10000
infirmiers anesthésistes en france qui
l'ont suivi un cursus de deux ans en
plus des trois années initiale en école
d'infirmière ce qui justifie donc
d'après eux un statut particulier
je vous propose à ce sujet d'écouter
deux manifestantes
nous faisons trois ans d'études
d'infirmiers 2 ans d'expérience minimum
en concours très difficile pour accéder
à l'école d'iliad et nous faisons deux
ans d'études supplémentaires attentes
plans etc avec des stages pratiques
donc notre niveau d'études est
équivalent à celui des sages femmes par
exemple qui eux sont reconnus comme
profession médicale
là on demande uniquement d'être reconnu
à juste titre comme les auxiliaires
médicaux avec les nouvelles lois ségur
et le nouveau dispositif ségur 2 il y
aurait plus qu'une dizaine voire m'a
même pas une vingtaine d'euros de
différence entre un infirmier qui
démarre et un infirmier anesthésiste qui
débute aussi donc une perte
d'attractivité maximale pour notre
métier est en fin de carrière il y
aurait à peu près 180 euros de
différence
donc ça ça nous met vraiment en
difficulté et on a peur que depuis peu
plus personne ne veuille faire notre
métier
d'autant qu'il est pas reconnue dans sa
spécificité par rapport à son autonomie
et son expertise
une délégation du syndicat national des
infirmiers anesthésistes a été reçu cet
après midi au ministère de la santé pas
par olivier ferrand mais par son
secrétaire de cabinet des échanges des
discussions ont eu lieu mais aucune
décision définitive n'a abouti ce
qu'attend olivier ferrand c'est en fait
un rapport de l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales qui devraient lui être
remis d'ici au mois de juillet ils
attendant que ce document avant de
pouvoir statuer en attendant les
infirmiers anesthésistes restent
mobilisés et déterminés à faire entendre
leurs revendications
il faut savoir qu'il devrait rejoindre
la grande journée d'action du 15 juin
prochain une journée qui devrait réunir
plusieurs corps de métiers du secteur de
santé